one of the world's favorite drinks is
coca-cola and for good reason it's
perfectly quenches thirst and gives a
little boost when we need it but does
this delicious beverage have a few more
tricks up its sleeve if you are a first
time you are click the red subscribe
button because today we are discussing
ten genius thing you can do with
coca-cola besides drink it hair
treatment it sounds crazy but putting
coking your hair can actually have some
pretty shocking results people started
putting cloaking their hair when actress
Suki Waterhouse confess she uses it to
achieve a pouty look it turns out coca
is a very low pH which helps make hair
look more full rinsing your hair with
coke causes the hair to too close to
Titan which makes it look smoother and
helps define curls the sugar in the coke
also gives hair of beating texture no
laundry detergent aid putting coke on
your clothes may seem like a no-no but
it can actually help maximize your
regular laundry detergent some of the
most difficult stains can struggle with
our grease stains you don't have to
spend a lot of money on expensive spa
treatments that may not work just grab a
can of coke and let it work its magic
surprisingly adding a can of coke to
your wash not only helps move past the
stains but also deodorizers smelly
clothing [ __ ] removal everyone knows the
gum and hair just don't mix from peanut
butter to cutting hair people have been
trying to find the best way to get gum
out of hair if you do find yourself with
gum stuck in your hair reach for a coke
all you have to do is soak the portion
of your heil with a gum is stuck for a
few minutes the gum should be easier to
get loose and there should be minimal
hair loss science experiment there are
many ways to have fun with coke other
than drinking it you could try one of
these interesting science experiments
the easiest experiment is the Mentos and
Diet Coke fountain experiments all you
need to do is drop one chewy Mentos mint
into a 2-liter bottle of Diet Coke and
washes it erupt if it's something more
stomach churning you like then try and
mix Milka Milka bottle of coke after
letting the milk interact with the coke
for 35 minutes to the mixture switch to
form a clear liquid with sediment at the
bottom this one will probably make you
rethink putting coke into your body
sucide it's hard to wrap our heads
around the fact that people use coke as
a pesticide something that we put into
our bodies actually is the capacity to
ward pests from truck the trend is
mostly used in India we're using coke is
more cost-effective than using expensive
pesticide apparently the high sugar
content of coke makes it lethal for
pests to consume of course this is
something the coca-cola company denied a
period using focused pesticide has yet
to be disproven breast removal getting
rust off items can get pretty tricky and
there are a lot of products in the
market that say they can do the trick
but if you really want to remove rust
look no further than your refrigerator
that's right folks - toric acid content
makers racing and moving run all you
have to do is soak your rusty items in a
bowl of coke for 24 hours then easily
scrub the rest off with a hard brush
it's that simple
compost catalyst if you are starting
your own garden then it may be shocking
to hear that coke can help you get
started compost is the decaying organic
matter that helps fertilize plan the
acids in coke can actually jump start to
decaying process and compost production
the sugars in coke can even attract bugs
and microorganisms just speed up the
compost process it's also believed that
porn coconut oil of acid loving plants
will help reduce the pH these bug bites
and stings enjoying a nice cold coke on
a summer day cannot only quench your
thirst but it can also help you cannot
be beat zinc many stinging insects like
bees and wasps have venom that is
alkaline based so when you applied close
to the aggravated sling area the acid
from the sting helps neutralize the
alkaline from the venom you can also use
coke to neutralize the toxic saliva that
causes mosquito bites to itch and swell
just make sure to bring wet wipes to
tech things may be a little sticking
toilet bowl cleaner poke seems to be a
one-stop shop when it comes to household
cleaners it's known to slice of the
toughest crime toilet bowls have to
offer the carbonation from the coke
helps break down clear bowls toast with
cheese
simply grab a can of coke and poured
into your toilet bowl let it sit for an
hour while it works its magic
finally use your toilet scrubbing brush
to effortlessly scrub away the grime car
battery hack using coke on a faulty car
battery is one of the old
tricks in the book people have been
using techniques for years because it
actually works most of the time when a
car won't start it's due to a dirty
battery terminal if that is the case all
you have to do is clear the battery
filled up to the can of coke so cokes
acidity works as an agent of premium
accumulation of oxidation that can cause
the battery to not start so it won't
help a dead battery and help save money
from not having to buy new car parts are
you surprised by all the ways you can
use coke react in the comment section
below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to the things